uh i mean i can remember situations with
mushrooms where
i hadn't taken it for a long time and i
fall into confusion
and it usually revolves around am i
doing the right
thing whatever the right thing so then
i'll take mushrooms
and wait until properly so and then
put this question am i doing the right
thing and
it reminds me of a um
press conference that lyndon johnson had
once shortly after he became president
somebody asked a question that he didn't
care for
and he said what kind of a chicken [ __ ]
question is that to ask the president of
the united states
so when i go to the mushroom
and say you know am i doing the right
thing it basically said what kind of a
chicken [ __ ]
question is that to ask me
[Laughter]
and i think that was a very good answer
that was what i needed to hear
you know are you kidding
me so
you know it can be you know my father
used to say you can drive a horse to
water but a pencil must be led
and i think that that's sort of the
situation
with the mushroom if the question
pleases it
it will answer if the question doesn't
please it you'll
you'll hear about it and it is amazing
how it gives people what they need you
know that rolling stone song you don't
always get what you want you get what
you need
uh i have a friend dear friend
but arrogant no doubt about it this guy
is arrogant he definitely thinks he has
his the truth by the throat in most
situations and he won't take mushrooms
because it gives him such a hard time
i mean and it says you know you're
arrogant you want to know what we do to
arrogant people
so for god's sake lift it off
so a certain amount of
a certain amount of humility it's a
relationship
like to a crusty zen
master or something like that and it is
really like another entity because
you cannot predict the answers i mean i
remember
a dialogue that i had with the mushroom
early on
where i said what are you doing
on this planet and it said
you're a mushroom you live cheap
and so so he said listen this
neighborhood was not so
bad till the monkeys moved in
to you it may look like a mess to me it
was paradise
the mushroom is very very weird i
i'll tell one more story then i'll try
and get off stories
but and all these stories why am i doing
all these uh
dialogue but why am i doing all these
ethnic imitations i'm not sure
there's one in this story too i was
in malibu with all these fancy film
people and we went out to dinner ralph
abraham was there too
and there was this french woman there a
film producer
and she was seated next to me at dinner
and before dinner we had been
talking about the mushroomer i had been
introduced to her as the mushroom man
and this and that
and she said to me um
and you'll see why the story i just told
relates to this
the story about you're a mushroom you
live cheap
um and she said to me at dinner she said
you say that
mushroom speaks to you but i do not
understand
exactly how this works and i said well
it's sort of like uh
it has many faces that it can
show like sometimes it's like the role
that rod steiger played in the pawn
broker
and at that precise instant
steiger shows up at the table to
shake hands with everybody and slap a
few backs and then he just drifts off
into the recesses of this restaurant
and ralph abraham who was sitting across
the table from me
watching this whole thing and had heard
what i said to this woman
reached across the table to me and said
you see
the mushroom is showing us that it can
touch us
anywhere anytime
strange stories synchronicity
[Music]
you